[Musique]
des couleurs des lignes claires et de la
puissance voilà en substance à
l'intention artistique de sites ou
matières
[Musique]
pour s'imposer au micro il y a pas de
lumière qui m'inspire beaucoup parce que
voilà dans mon travail je parle beaucoup
de cohabitation de vivre ensemble donc
vu que le rugby c'est un sport d'équipe
et que faut se faire des pâtes faut se
comprendre pour pouvoir avancer et
gagner
tout et donc inspiré par ce mur de 7
mètres de haut lui qui a été joueur de
rugby plus jeune faire ici une
performance au stade Tonnellé rien de
plus évident
de pays ont des couleurs qui qui parlent
le vert le vert le bleu voilà après on a
le rouge l'orange donc c'est des
couleurs qui me parlent face à une
couleur on sourit toujours et ça ça nous
ça nous donne de l'énergie pour la
journée
considéré comme un pionnier de l'air
urbain au Togo si tout maintient
l'ancien parisien était prédestiné à la
finance aujourd'hui il vit dans l'Oise
mais reste un éternel globeteur du
Sénégal à la Belgique en passant par le
Bénin si tout quadrille le monde pour y
laisser son empreinte faut être
disponible le graffeur n'avait jamais pu
venir à tour une ville où la rurbain
connaît un essor important depuis
maintenant deux ans porté par
l'association lemur tour on aime dans
dans son travail c'est c'est son style
haut en couleur
et la façon dont il travaille autour de
la mosaïque avec des lignes de force qui
donne de la puissance et du mouvement
fédérer les cultures
être
comment être donné à voir l'art au plus
grand nombre
c'est vraiment des valeurs qui nous
animent
atelier exposition fresque ou encore
participation à des festivals si tout
est en perpétuelle mouvement tour aurait
su l'apprécier le temps de quelques
jours